maison en flammes d'autres en ruines
elles ont été frappées par l'artillerie
russe qui vise sans relâche la ville de
l'itie de chances que sur place les
habitants boivent vivre au rythme des
bombes
il ya eu une explosion qui la maison a
commencé à trembler et les échafaudages
ont commencé à tomber partout nous
n'avons même pas compris ce qui s'est
passé
d'un côté comme de l'autre les imbéciles
doivent se mettre d'accord parce que
c'est toujours les gens innocents qui
souffrent
les combats intenses ont dévasté la
commune depuis plusieurs jours elle est
privée d'eau potable d'électricité à
côté de l'iscid chance qu la ville
voisine de severodonezk situé de l'autre
côté d'une rivière une zone devenue la
dernière poche de résistance ukrainienne
dans cette région de lougansk à 50 km au
sud à bach mouthe la situation est tout
aussi difficile
[Musique]
en colère certains habitants accusent
volodymyr zelensky d'abandonner l'est de
l'ukraine il a oublié le dombass ils ne
se soucient que de kiev il a oublié
donetsk est lougansk ils sont rares à
choisir de rester sur place beaucoup ont
déjà fui dans des trains d'évacuation
spéciaux mis en place par les autorités
ukrainiennes leur seule chance
d'échapper au combat